cooking steak can be a little bit
daunting with all the different options
and price points so whether you're
buying a cheap or an expensive cut of
steak it's more about how you treat it
and how you're cooking with it that's
going to make the biggest difference
even if it's a cheap steak you can still
get great results so we're going to go
over some cheap and expensive cuts of
steak and ways to cook them both so
steak is just a term for a cut of meat
that doesn't have a lot of connective
tissue which makes it suitable for quick
cooking there's a number of options when
you're looking at inexpensive steaks a
good list to work off of are hanger
steaks tri-tip flap chuck eye steak or
chuck tenders hanger is also known as
kind of the butcher steak chuck means
it's just coming from the shoulder it's
a little bit more muscular because the
shoulder does a lot of work and it's
life but it also has a good amount of
marbling and great flavor as well so
because it is coming from the shoulder
it will be a little bit tougher texture
than some of the other more expensive
cuts and could be used for a lot of
different things even outside of steak
which we're not going to get into
another great flavor as well as textured
steak is a tri-tip this one you'll
definitely be able to recognize right
away because of its unique shape it
actually does have three separate kind
of points to it this one can be a little
bit more difficult to work with the size
varies a bit so by the time you get the
middle cooked the outside or the edges
could be a little bit overdone what you
could do is cut this up into smaller
pieces and treat them more like
individual fillets flab meat all right
flat meat
not the sexiest
name this is similar to skirt steak or
flank but as those have become more
popular they're a little bit more
expensive in the grocery stores now so
flap is a great option it's a little bit
different as you can see the texture is
quite loose that can be really great
because it soaks up marinades really
really well it's got a great color
though it looks like a prehistoric
fossil in some way while this piece can
be quite large you can cut it into
different pieces freeze part of it and
cook some for dinner tonight this one
would work great for a marinade since
it's going to take on so much flavor and
all those little crevices you don't have
to do anything crazy but adding just a
little bit of low sodium soy sauce some
fresh ground black pepper and a few
crushed cloves of garlic would be a
great simple marinade you can throw
together really easily all you need to
do is put a clove underneath your palm
push down and just kind of bruise it a
bit it's going to crack it open a little
bit and just help the flavor release
without having to do a lot of chopping
or mincing and you can let this sit in
the marinade for anywhere from 30
minutes to overnight getting out all the
air and then just kind of move the meat
around in the bag and make sure that
everything's touching the marinade and
then before you cook you want to make
sure that you dry off the marinade and
get as much of it off as you can you
want to have a nice dry steak so you can
get a good crust on it if there's too
much moisture left the meat is going to
steam when you put it on the hot skillet
instead of getting a nice crispy crust
using paper towels is great for this
because it still is raw meat and you can
throw them away right after the cast
iron skillet is a great option no matter
what type of steak you're cooking cast
iron holds heat really well but as
you'll find in the other cast iron video
that we did it doesn't heat up very
evenly so if you wanted to preheat your
cast iron skillet in a hot oven for
about 20 minutes that would be a good
option once it's preheated you can go
ahead and pour in a good amount of oil
you can use any type of cooking oil
ideally something with a high smoke one
once you're sure that your skillet and
your oil are preheated you can go ahead
and carefully layer your steak in it
should immediately sizzle there's kind
of two rules of thought on cooking
steaks whether you should flip it often
or flip it once we like to flip ours
quite frequently throughout the cooking
process to ensure that we're keeping an
eye on the entire piece of meat and
getting a good crust throughout also by
consistently flipping and moving the
steak you're ensuring that you're
putting the steak on the hottest parts
of the pan which are going to give you
the best crust especially if you're new
to cooking steak and you're not as
comfortable just feeling the meat to see
if it's done it's always a good idea to
have a kitchen thermometer on hand the
most foolproof way is to use a
thermometer poking right into the center
of the steak which is going to be the
coolest part for a medium rare steak you
want to serve it at 135 degrees
fahrenheit you can take it off a few
degrees earlier because it's going to
carry over cooking slightly no matter
what steak you're cooking you always
want to let it sit for a good five to
ten minutes after it comes off this
gives me time to let the carryover
cooking take place the steak will be
more even temperature throughout and it
also helps the meat relax a little bit
the high heat is going to make all those
fibers kind of tense up and resting will
then relax a little bit and be a nicer
texture in your mouth this is one that
you definitely want to cut against the
grain because those fibers are so loose
you can really see where they are just
going to make sure that it's a little
bit easier to chew it's going to be a
nicer texture in your mouth sometimes
people are freaked out by the red juice
that comes out of a resting steak that's
actually not blood it's myoglobin it's
just a protein in the muscle fibers
mixed with the water and residual
moisture that's left in the meat some of
the cheaper cuts of steak have a little
bit of a stronger flavor so they're
great to use the marinades because that
beef flavor can stand up to the flavors
in a marinade if you are looking to
indulge a little bit more there's a lot
of great options on the higher end as
well starting with the new york strip
steak this is kind of your starter steak
if you will it has a good amount of fat
a good bit of marbling it's going to be
more tender than something like a chuck
and have a beard flavor some key
indicators are the fat cap along the
outside as well as pretty good marbling
throughout it's also called a kansas
city chip steak or a sirloin steak the
tenderloin or the filet is going to be
the most expensive of all the options
because it's coming from a very small
part that is right under the spine does
almost no movement throughout its life
therefore it's very very tender it
almost melts in your mouth a nice
tenderloin should still have a good
amount of marbling throughout should be
a nice bright color some say that
doesn't have as much flavor we are
paying for here is the really soft
texture and the rarity in the sense that
it's a very small part that comes out of
the cow ribeye is also known to be one
of the most preferred and most expensive
steaks has a good balance of marbling
texture and flavor there should be good
large chunks of fat throughout it you
can get a rib eye bone in or out some
people will say that the bone imparts a
lot more flavor but like i don't
necessarily feel like it makes a big
difference but it's you know a nice show
stopper if you're looking for a medium
rare center going about one and a half
to two inches is preferred so that you
can get a nice crust on the outside
while still preserving that medium rare
center which highlights the flavor and
the texture that you're paying for with
the rib eye if you want something that's
a little bit more well done i actually
wouldn't recommend going with a thicker
cut steak so with a steak like this it
really doesn't need much seasoning the
purest way is just with salt and you can
do this at least an hour before you're
about to cook it you can even salt it
overnight what that's going to do is
give the salt more time to penetrate
it's going to help flavor as well as
tenderize if you're going to be salting
it overnight we recommend covering with
cling film it's only going to be for an
hour or so you can actually just put it
in the fridge uncovered so what we're
going to do is actually do the opposite
of the traditional sear then bake method
we're going to bake ahead of time and
sear later what this is going to do is
we're going to slowly raise the
temperature of the steak in a low oven
and we're going to put that in for about
30 minutes until the internal
temperature is around 90 or 95 degrees
at that point we're going to take it out
get a really really high heat on our
cast iron skillet again it should sizzle
right away it should be a really really
hot pan the great thing about the
reverse sear method is that you're
cooking the meat itself in the oven and
then you're just finishing it off in the
skillet to get a really great crust on
the outside there's a little bit wide
over margin of error here because the
temperature in the oven is going to be
much lower than on a hot skillet so you
have more time and wiggle room to get
the temperature right before you're
searing it on the outside if you're
going to cut into slices it's a great
idea to cut the bone out first it's
going to make it a lot easier because we
gradually rose the temperature of the
meat in the oven before it's not as much
of a shock to the meat when you're
throwing in a hot skillet it doesn't
need to rest as long as a pan seared
steak would the texture is quite fine
and doesn't make as big of a difference
the way that you cut it of course it's
great to cut it across the grain but
it's not going to be as striking of a
difference really all you need to cook a
great steak is thermometer good cast
iron skillet a lot of salt and some oil
[Music]
bye